[Music]
so-called paper record The New York
Times yesterday sinks to a new low
when they published an op-ed thomas
friedman titled keep up the blanket
coverage of Trump it hurts him all the
news that is fit to print indeed this is
the same newspaper that recently hired
Sarah Zhang to its editorial board now
you may want to remember she's the one
who among other things tweeted the
hashtag canceled white people she wrote
that she gets quote joy out of being
cruel to old white men also took pride
in her hatred for president Trump
writing quote I was equated Trump to
Hitler before it was cool and of course
F the police so many times it's hard to
count when I was with reaction author of
the briefing politics press the people
in New York Times best seller former
White House press secretary Sean Spicer
author of why we fight Fox News national
security strategist dr. Sebastian Gorka
Sean these are all friends of yours this
is the New York time well look I think
they recognize they the media Research
Center did an analysis that 92% of the
coverage against President Trump has
been negative so I'm not much how much
sure there's more to throw at him but
the reality is is that he's getting
things done is an approval rating shows
it
he unemployment rates at three point
nine percent more blacks and Hispanics
are employed than ever before the gross
the GDP hit a new level at four point
one percent the deregulatory State is
going down the judiciary is getting
remade I mean all of these things no
matter how hard the press tries to go
against the president he continues to
get results for the American people so I
get that it's frustrating for someone
like mr. Friedman to see the no matter
how much they fight against him that he
continues to succeed and I think the
American people are smarter than he
understands and they are actually
showing it with their with their
approval rating so no matter how hard
they try he's getting results dr. Gork I
look at the higher the New York Times
and I'm I just sit here and I look at
all these groups they love to attack
every conservative talk radio host
everybody on the Fox News Channel that
has an opinion even you and Sean and
and pretty much anybody they disagree
with and I'm wondering let's just flip
the script and say that Oh a
conservative said these things all these
groups that get paid millions and
millions of dollars to silence and
boycott and attack and go to advertisers
they're kind of silent over this I'm
shocked
none of them are journalists all those
people and my former colleague Sean
Spicer had to deal with at the podium
they're activists they're political
activists doesn't matter whether it's
the New York Times The Daily Beast
Huffington Post they are all activists
Thomas Friedman is why Donald Trump is
president this opinion piece tells you
everything you need to know sure what
did he actually saying that piece he
said don't focus on the facts don't
focus on the economy the lack of
unemployment the roaring trade economics
we've got to take him down that's the
left they haven't learned anything in
the last two years and the result in the
special elections this week and the
primaries tell you everything that they
have not learned but hey it's great roll
on November I don't think any balls for
granted I want to be very clear here I
think this is the most important midterm
impeach the president you know no vision
to help the Forgotten men and women in
this country no consideration Obama
failed and Trump has great economic
success foreign policy success keep
Obamacare eliminate eyes keep open
borders they want their crumbs back and
they want these investigations to stop
and yeah Devin Nunez was right hey Shawn
okay here's what I'm going to tell you
right now yeah that yeah and here's the
reality that if you if the Democrats
were to take control of the house all
you're gonna do is add more and more
investigations 24 hours a day that's
what their agenda is and all of the
ability of President Trump to get his
agenda where the Republican House is
gonna stop people have to understand
that President Trump may not be on the
ballot this November but his agenda
certainly is we need to go out there
with the same fervor that we elected the
president with you this November and
keep Oh Republican House yeah doctor
Gorka what do you say like we'll give
you the last word I think
20:18 is potentially more important than
November 2016 fake news is real the
president is right to hit back ignore
them get on social media repost the
president find the facts out for
yourself and ask yourself one thing what
do you think of the last year and a half
if you like it that's what we need to
vote they got a no this is really in a
large way about President Trump and
destroying and stop his agenda they've
got to understand this is to undermine
the [ __ ] they had in 2016
Sean the reality is and you said it
earlier they're gonna destroy anybody
that tries to support the president
they've sent now fake protesters
supported by people like Samantha B to
come after me this is the problem
anybody who's with this president right
now they will do whatever they can to
destroy them and I think we have to make
it very clear right now what we're up
against got it all right guys good to
see you both